[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris mannix joining us on short notice
the
sports illustrated nba senior writer
with the big news with the boston
celtics uh
danny ainge stepping down brad stevens
moving up
what is going on in boston chris well
the decision by danny ainge to step
down is not surprising um it's been in
the water supply dan
for the last few months that ange was
considering stepping away strongly
considering
stepping away he's been the top
basketball executive
since 2003 and frankly there's a shelf
life
for jobs like these you get a little bit
burnt out
doing jobs like these for one specific
franchise and i think danny
had reached his limit his legacy in
boston
is completely secure he won a
championship ending
uh a 20-plus year drought he
orchestrated
arguably the biggest heist in nba trade
history
with what he did with that deal with
brooklyn and
this season notwithstanding the way it
ended the celtics are pretty well set up
i mean jayson tatum
is an mvp candidate jalen brown is a
first-time all-star
they've got a good mix of young players
that you know comprise a pretty
solid young core so he's leaving the
celtics
in pretty good shape now the decision to
hire brad stevens
as president of basketball operations is
mind-boggling
like brad stevens is i think
a top five coach in the nba as we've
seen
countless times that does not always
mean
you are a great basketball executive pat
riley was able to do it
a handful of others have been able to do
it but
hiring brad stevens as the head coach or
as the
the basically the fact ogm is is wild to
me
it really is especially dan when
you consider it against the backdrop of
who the celtics
had a shot at and that's sam presti in
oklahoma city
sam presti is widely regarded as
top two top three maybe number one gm in
all of basketball
he's also from concord massachusetts he
played his college basketball
at emerson in downtown boston and like
danny ainge
sam presti could have been looking for
other opportunities
presti has been the gm in oklahoma city
so long there were the
sonics when he first took over so he
could be looking around
at different options and to not even
gauge
his interest in that job is tantamount
to basketball malpractice
it really is i am i am the biggest fan
of brad stevens as a head coach i have
vociferously defended him
over the years against kind of people
attacking him for for different things
you know how he's coached the team and
the team tuning him out the idea that
you hire brad stevens as your bat top
basketball exec
and not make a run at sam presti is
shocking to me
okay but who allowed this why brad
stevens is giving up coaching at age 44
well well brad stevens can always go
back to coaching it's not like
his it's not his reputation is not
damaged at any point if brad stevens was
a coaching free agent right now
you'd have a handful of teams firing
their coaches to get their hands on them
it is it hasn't taken a hit he's never
going back to college basketball i swear
to god if somebody
commits one more tv radio segment to
that they're insane
he's not doing it ever ever ever okay
but why did they allow this to happen
in the celtics organization that the
best guy you can get to coach
is now going to be your
he's going to be searching for a coach
well i think danny ainge
um played a big part in this in
organizing his line of success this
didn't happen dan
overnight where you know brad went to
management after the net series and said
you know what
i kind of want to do something different
this has been in the works for a while
so you know it's been carefully planned
and mapped out for a long time remember
danny
danny's got some skin in the game here
in that selfish organization quite
literally his son
is one of the basketball executives with
that team austin he's got a long
relationship with
guys like mike zaran and assistant gm
dave lewin who runs the scouting
department like
i think there's a part of danny that
wanted to make sure his guys were taken
care of so
i think he played a role in this and
ownership which just recently gave brad
stevens
a new long-term contract loves the guy
so
yeah we've seen familiarity play a big
role in
jobs like this getting filled i just
think it's i can't
i can't understand like sam presley's
out there
he's out there he has set up oklahoma
city
as well as you can set them up for the
future 17 first-round draft picks
18 second-round draft picks through
2027. the line of succession in oklahoma
city
is right there rob hennigan is your
former gm in orlando long time
right hand man for presti is there to be
elevated as gm
how do you not call this guy how do you
not make a run
at arguably the best gm at all of
basketball i don't understand it it
completely blows my mind
talking to chris mannix the senior nba
writer for sports illustrated
so who do the celtics hire to be their
next head coach
i have absolutely no idea because brad
stevens
he doesn't have like a coaching lineage
like i
you can say does he look to his own
staff and bring in jay laranega who has
been a coaching candidate in the past
an excellent basketball mind scott
morrison who coached
as a head coach of the g league and
excellent basketball mind they've got
smart guys on their staff
but i would bet that given the way the
last few seasons have kind of played out
there's a desire to uh bring in a new
voice
somebody different to to take over tatum
and brown
and and those guys and try to take them
to the next level
but i have no idea like nobody has any
idea like what who brad stevens likes as
a head coach
who he might hire what ranks he might
dip into it's a
a total blank slate when it comes to
brad stevens as a basketball executive
thanks for joining us on short notice
chris we appreciate your time and uh
love your passion i'm very upset right
now dan it's going to come across
in the digital ink that i'm going to
spill in the next few hours
yeah but your phoenix suns got the win
last night oh
yes now we're talking hey got that audio
seating
yeah that's what i thought you only
saved the bad stuff
bring on the good stuff a manic no no no
they have to win the series not win last
night they have to win the series chris
all right well if they win that series
the t-shirt has to spain is stacked
i'm gonna change it few suns are good
all right
thank you chris you got that that's
chris mannix